- [Instructor] How has the debate
over Reagan's policies evolved into today?
- When Reagan was making the case for,
basically, they called
it the Reagan revolution,
because it was a real departure
from the way the federal
government had been
existing in American life.
The debate had mostly
been between Democrats
and Republicans over to how
best manage the government.
Ronald Reagan came in and said no.
Just get government out
of the conversation.
That has continued to
bounce along in politics,
there was the most major
fight on those lines
with Newt Gingrich and
president Bill Clinton.
Since then, there have been pockets of it,
but the appetite for deficit reduction,
for shrinking government
in order to make sure
that the bills are paid by government,
has kind of gone out
of favor in Washington.
It was a very big deal during the '90s and
during the first 10 years of this century,
but it has not really been as much a part
of the conversation in
politics as it once was.
It once dominated the way
people talked about government.
Now there are other things that are taking
the conversation away.